Demaryius Thomas said on Sunday there's
a 50/50 chance he'll be traded and IKEA
he was right the 50 that came up was
trade and not to the Patriots like some
had thought the Houston Texans have
acquired Demaryius Thomas from the
Broncos for a fourth round pick and a
swap of seventh rounders and now the
Texans who had a clear need at the
position after last week's torn ACL
suffered by will fuller will welcome to
his Thomas to Houston and then they'll
all pack up and go on the road this week
to play yes the Broncos in Denver so
Thomas who was a first-round pick of the
Broncos in 2010 will play his first game
as not a member of the Broncos against
the Broncos in the stadium that has been
his home stadium all these years and it
could be a great situation for him I
know he was upset about the possibility
being traded in the uncertainty but
typically you get traded from a non
contender to a contender and the Texans
are clearly a contender in first place
in the AFC South and now you've got the
opportunity to win games get to the
postseason and maybe chase another Super
Bowl ring and if all these other Texans
players can stay healthy
then Demaryius Thomas can really add
something to an offense that has deshaun
Watson that has DeAndre Hopkins that has
a running game that is effective when
needed the offensive line better than
it's been and the defense is very good
so the Texans making a move at not a
huge expense to try to get themselves in
position to win the division and make
some noise in January and demerist
Thomas gets a chance to make some noise
in Denver coming this Sunday hi I'm Mike
Tirico and thanks for watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from NBC Sports